the timing couldn't be worse days away
from children going back to school after
the summer break now facing closures and
disruptions
at this Sheffield School pupils are
learning under a 60 year old roof at
risk of collapse
in places the ceilings held up by wooden
props
the materials known as rack reinforce
autoclaved aerated concrete used from
the 1950s up to the mid-1990s that's
outlived its 30-year lifespan
Corpus Christi School in Brixton South
London is one of the schools forced to
partially close while the problems dealt
with after rack was found in parts of
the roof
it's going to be difficult but it's the
best solution right we all just have to
work together parents can work out a
solution to help each other get the kids
to school
the government's trying to assure
parents the problem is under control but
has left teachers scrambling to find
Alternatives including mobile containers
in which they continued teaching and for
some pupils who returned to pandemic
style remote learning hasn't been ruled
out
156 out of our 22 and a half thousand
schools so for most people you won't be
affected but for those priority for me
is the children's your children's safety
and that's why we're taking these
precautionary measures the problem is
it's not just schools that are affected
other public buildings constructed in
the 50s 60s and 70s including
universities courts and hospitals also
contain the dangerous concrete the
material has been known about for some
time with unsafe rack identified and
removed but new evidence emerged in
recent weeks suggesting low risk rack is
actually dangerous schools and other
buildings that were thought to be safe
were anything but need Barker Al Jazeera
London
new additions to the list of UNESCO
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera